das kennt
deswegen gott bist du dumm sind jetzt
einfach mein oder wie ein kokon mein
kopf vor mir gestorben
bestimmt genau wir können auch einfach
nicht dank alter sind das viele aber das
ist relativ leicht weil die kann keine
rüstung an
okay nicht hoch ich bin ich bin direkt
hinter die hier ist eine kiste mit
schuhen und alle möglichen mit so viele
sachen
das ist eigentlich mache jetzt werde ich
gleich ausprobieren
ich sag jetzt mal ganz kurz welche sache
nicht ich brauche dieses papier warum
ich das kenn ich verlasse davon 3
warum hätte ich gebraucht europas auf
ich möchte meine markierte test mit den
leuten hier alter ein schlag tot
ich will zeigen oder kampf wartet ganz
meine familie haben einfach bei einem
bisschen pfeile uns komplett leder
rüstung pfeile m25 sniper brocken
baseboard bett usb flash drive breakdown
networks in der kiste drin leistung habe
ich keinen für dich habe ich 23 aber die
brauche ich auch selber ist dank
freakshow
wir sind in der freakshow mit mach ich
jetzt richtig ab damit machte das geil
mit markierte cycle tot
ich hab nicht alle er doch die auch
alter sagt bei mir super mit meinem
tollen pc hier ja ich habe ja in aller
schießt irgendeiner alter richtig viele
ja ja gesagt
naja hab ich ganz am anfang gesagt
zombie apokalypse weil das ist krass
viele zombies was verlangt der von euch
mit
und das ist nicht okay ich bin ja
gespannt
ja das nochmal auf hardware okay wir
sind auch keine prozesse ungefähren
solchen lane spielen wartet mal
versuchen geht ganz leute ich versuche
den typen da hinten abzuknallen zu
sterben aber das ist richtig krass das
normale say okay ist ja normal und nicht
weil er so ein typ ist der soling
schießt aber den können ganz einfach
abschießen
die braker ich bin vergiftet ich weiß
nicht ich regeneriere ich weiß nicht
vielleicht hab ich noch weiter ich weiss
nicht halbes jahr zeit habe ich halt
sehr leicht durch die vergiftung an
jetzt geht stimmt da warte ich bin weg
zu dir wo bist du her wo bisher gelaufen
hier oben ja dass du hast mich oben sind
alle teams ja ich weiß da unten angeht
aber die last im spiel nicht mehr dahin
wo es weitergeht sondern auch zur
nebensache nehmen welches jahr guck da
ist eine kiste mit einer eisen hose
verrottet ist frei stellt als rose weil
ich jetzt nur die nämlich die habe ich
gefunden weil es weitergehen
pech weitergehen willst wenn wir wenn
ihre echten apokalypse werden welche
abgeben
für die opfer halten daher brauche jetzt
auch keiner schreiben wer würde es nicht
machen es ist einfach homo oeconomicus
jeder denkt an sich selber
sein spiel ja aber man kann trotzdem
sterben arschloch ich bin nicht mehr
raus alle hier sind ganz viele zombies
ich komme nicht mehr aus
ich weiß nicht ich bin einfach
reingegangen und jetzt kommt nicht mehr
raus auswahl wenn ich vielleicht die zu
mir sie bedeute hier kommt immer mehr
essen knochen kartoffeln passen müssen
erstmal etwas essen als creme kann ich
ihm nicht erst nicht was es ist
ich habe zwei eisenwaren das heißt ich
könnte reisen schwert machen
ich habe eine machete ist aber gut sechs
damit nicht immer zusammen enchantment
table geschafft
dank der heilung lernen du dir das geld
so ich lese schon mal mission drei vor
mission 21
den wecker töten das ist aber optional
und wir sollen den große restore finden
also ein geschäft ich habe hier
unglaubliche frame ein wo ich immer so
zwischendurch
es ist richtig heftig schauen wir hier
oben noch ob die noch etwas drin ist
oder aus der kiste den helm soll ich
alles reisen 1 da ist man mit den ganzen
sachen hast du schon diamanten so sachen
zum handeln habe ich mal nachgeguckt und
da brauchen also bestimmte sachen und zu
diamanten zu bekommen level 33 folgen so
ein chart mend alter ja okay wir
schlagen einfach einen krieg und dann
explodieren die die ganze zombies mit
einer luft genau wo bist du jetzt
eingefallen ich nicht rein
zombie zombies müssen wir eine tolle
sniper
so man haben die vier jahren leben
menschen ihr leben als mit dem bogen
sind drei schüsse aber ich hab keine
pfeile mir das natürlich dann suboptimal
wo bist du
ich frage mich gerade wohl bist was du
da unten alle euro-staaten wir ganz kurz
vorweg ich muss kurz dessen appetit
warum sind wieder leute warten
nimm du die am ende der straße und
importiert weil ich auf den knopf
gedrückt hat wir sind in allen kissen
jetzt gar nichts drin aber hier sind
zombies bestehende gleich einfach auf
eine höher gelegene position umstellen
das ist einfach level 35 jetzt ich höre
da schon wieder neue kommen
ich will am liebsten einfach pfeile euro
ganz viele ganz viele wälder überleben
aber das kann ich ja wohl es tut mir
leid
ach du bist du ja ich bin schier welche
acht alter und drei herzen zwei halte
ich will doch nur was essen meine lieben
freunde ja okay das schaffe ich glaube
ich ihm die runde alter das kann ich
nicht schaffen
guck mal wie viele bei mir sind das
thema von den hass auf diese scheiß
zombies mohammed
ach du scheiße vermehren
die fed gepanzert deswegen entweder
sterben oder kämpfen
also entweder sterben kämpfen oder essen
und man kann halt nicht
39 840 auf jetzt vielleicht ganz kurz
mal was essen gerne oder factory store
wissen du hier kosten abziehen
ich lebe
ich bin verzaubert was habe ich hunger
auf teamwork in den garten generator
fixen wie kannst du dir denn dort immer
ganz kurz mit inventar wofür brauche ich
knochen jetzt alle meine sachen
verbrauch braucht da rein so kann die
schwarzburger bräunig ausmachen behalte
ich erstmal knochen treue auch nicht bei
scream krone bei auch nicht brauche ich
die behalte ich brocken baseballschläger
noch einen magneten kann man sich
eigentlich hier so munition kann ich
gebrauchen aber kann man sich nicht
kaufen
es brauche ich nicht das war nicht das
euere nicht dass wir nicht usb flash
drive weiß nicht was damit machen soll
war halt dass mir erst mal vielleicht
zum hacken oder so vielleicht bauen wir
das später irgendwann viel zu viel habe
ich hier hast du dir jetzt eine rüstung
verzaubert ich hab sie nicht verzaubern
ich habe dir gekauft was denn mit diesem
komischen glasteil dass deswegen gott
bist du dumm
wir sind jetzt einfach mein oder wie ich
bin also zu wenig keine rüstung abgebe 2
gasgvv sind diamanten rüstung alter
junge
wie viel hast du gar kein ich habe dir
doch alle gegeben
na gut lass weitergehen ja vorher
hattest du besser bist du hast doch auch
eisen rüstung
die hast du doch reingelegt in den dom
herum liegen hier soll das einfach
hängen muss erst mal kurz noch heil
nicht erst mal ein steak
das einfach alles mit vielleicht kann
man ja irgendwas handeln